[Music]
one of the things that we are often
asked in a game of chess is when do we
sacrifice our queen for three pieces or
when do we sacrifice our queen for two
rooks and upon so according to our
material chart a queen for three pieces
nine and nine that's even a queen for
two rooks if you can get the two rooks
that's worth 10 and you get a pawn
that's worth 10 so that's a good trade
or an even trade but it's not that
simple
really it and I try to emphasize this as
much as I can it's really not important
what comes off the board
it's what stays on the board you know
you can enjoy the fact or a rook up look
at that rook but if you're getting
checkmated and I'm having much joy out
of being a rook ahead so while we can
use the material table as a helpful
guide to understanding what's going on
in truth we really should be focused on
what's left on on the board and when our
focus is there what we really want or
need if we're the player who's given up
the Queen
we need active pieces or active rooks
it's really that simple
if our pieces are not active if our
rooks are not active we're in trouble
that was not a good Queen trade for us
let's just give a few examples okay our
first example comes from a very standard
Greenfeld defense very standard
Greenfeld the throne I think they even
call this
Moscow variation or something like that
it goes like this
Queen B 3 takes Queen takes castles
before I believe a six now this position
actually was made famous by none other
than vasily smyslov I think vasily
smyslov was really really underestimated
as a world champion all these world
champions have greatness but in truth he
was really overshadowed by the fact that
when he after he defeated smear Slav he
lost after Smith Slav defeated bud
Vinick
he lost the return match and was like
bad Vinick had this long long history as
world champion and bought Vinick is
referred to as the patriarch of the
Soviet chess federation but look at
their games together I think I'm in the
right neighborhood they played a hundred
and eighteen games over World
Championship matches
World Championship events Soviet events
and Smee sloth was like plus three had a
plus score against against Bob Vinick he
keeps the championship title for one
year but Vinick keeps that 17 or how
many years he did and everybody praises
the hell out of auditing Smee sloths had
this very very interesting idea the idea
of night night comes back was to give
this bishop a view of the board and
after for example Bishop III Smee sloth
made this position quite famous playing
numerous games in modern chess or jessep
today a seven a six has been a very
popular move by black II five B five
Queen B 3 okay
Queen b3 okay at first sight it does
appear that blacks in a bit of it a jam
he's kind of he's not a happy camper the
night has to move the knight on f6 has
to move if it moves to let's say g h5
well it's just on the rim it's dim it's
out of the game if it moves to say g4
well that's not as such a great square
either and after it moved like h3 the
night ends up being misplaced once again
on the side of the board so by far and
what black players have oh pardon me let
me just say nightly d7 after 9b d7
there's this very nasty movie 7 e 6 this
puts a lot of pressure on blacks
position once more because we can see
for example after a move like takes
Knight g5 white is going to win his pawn
back on e6 and have a very nice attack
so by far the theoreticians of the world
have chosen the move Bishop e6 so this
really puts the question to white well
what are you gonna do about your queen
what are you gonna do bout your queen if
white moves his queen back to c2 well
this is very nice from blacks point of
view because now blacks Knight has an
excellent square in the middle of the
board and white may have regrets that he
advanced his center pawns prematurely so
you're you have to imagine yourself
sitting on on the white side of the
situation for a moment and you say if I
move my Queen Queen C 295 black stands
very well so let me capture this Knight
I assume that he will capture my queen I
will capture this bishop threatening the
roots excuse me threatening the rook
he'll capture my pawn and I will
recapture the bishop so at the end of
all of these trades we've got a
situation of two bishops of the night
three pieces against a queen but black
also has one upon so armed the strict
material count tables blacks ahead okay
but as we start to look at the position
and Grandmaster practice have shown that
this position is actually favorable for
white much of the reason has to do
strangely enough with blacks King that
blacks King even though it doesn't look
really vulnerable at the moment it ends
up being quite vulnerable as it turns
out so let's imagine just for argument's
sake we're just going to imagine that
White's threatening to play the move
Bishop takes b5 thanks to the pin
against the rook on a8 let's imagine
that therefore black develops his knight
so that his rook is protected by the
Queen and Bishop takes b5 his off loops
is off the board and at the same time we
have ideas like Knight takes d4 okay
pawn on d4 is attacked lets us play
Bishop e3 defending the pawn okay
still it's not quite visible it's not
quite visible yet but if we have if we
imagine that the pawn comes to d5
followed by the bishop coming to d4 we
start to understand that blacks King has
a chance of being vulnerable so let's
play the move Knight V for we're
threatening Knight see to check we
defend the threat and I believe that
a number of Grandmaster games have gone
in this position now we can talk about
plans for a moment if I were white I'd
really like to play the move h4 h5 takes
on g6 takes on g6 Bishop h6 check and
take a look also if I was white I would
really like to play the move 95 Bishop
e2 castles and play Bishop f3 and
control the center most players if I'm a
whiff I've got this right play the move
Knight d5 here white plays Bishop g5 and
this is where you start to get a little
bit concerned about what's going on with
your King if you end up playing a move
like f7 f6 for just a moment I'll
retreat with my bishop it's very hard to
see how why how black pardon me is going
to develop his game and why and White's
mind he wants to play the move Bishop g3
with with tactics like Knight takes d5
and row pick C c7 he wants to play after
Bishop g3 moves like Bishop d3 Bishop
efore in other words it's very easy to
see that White's pieces are getting good
squares so this sacrifice of the Queen
black players have been distracted
discouraged them from it we go back we
do another one
efore variation d6 we're gonna go into a
perk for a moment
g3 night here Bishop here Bishop here be
believable how does this go Bishop c4
yeah it's castles Queen to Bishop g4 I'm
sure I think I'm getting it poor I think
I think I'm getting it something like
this like this like this like this like
this like this like this this this this
is very easy to see that white is doing
extremely well from the material count
yeah he's going to end up having a rook
and Knight and a bishop so the line that
I'm trying to get goes like Bishop c4
Bishop g4 we yeah Bishop g4 new
variation Queen e2 knight c6 d4 takes
takes takes
hey hey come on you're gonna hear okay
and I think I'm trying to play Knight
takes e - doesn't matter
or doesn't matter yeah I think it
doesn't matter I apologize
so Bishop takes e - new variation rook
takes here okay so here we have three
pieces for the Queen and two pawns in
the other variation we had just a pawn
and once again the practice has shown
that it's that what it can't what what
came off the board isn't as critical as
what stays on the board it turns out
that even though it looks like black
positions pretty solid White's play is
extremely fast in this position he
plates Bishop h6 attacks the rook
castles Queen d7 rook here I believe
castles a I think we do something like
this and it's not at all clear what
black is going to do against I mean it's
almost like every time he loses lose one
of his pawns for example of why it's
black were to move one of his pawns here
he immediately gives an outpost for we
could play Bishop here or more
concretely we could go Knight e4 to f6
so this is an example where your queen
for two pawns and again the practice has
shown that it's favorable for the pieces
the pieces now let's go back a moment to
another sacrifice I always say that
David Brownstein he's the root of all
evil
and the guys just like amazing you go
outside to our chests library there you
go through the encyclopedia of chess
openings a massive fight tune volume of
openings you're good you just like
select the random volume it's like
random pages it's almost for sure ideas
of Bronstein are going to be him of ages
so David Bronstein's I'm sure in
previous lectures I've mentioned this I
was black against Garry Kasparov
and I chose one of David Bronstein's
ideas
Garry played a Samish against me and I
sacrificed my queen for two bishops
this is David Bronstein's idea so I went
upon and after Queen here
I took a bishop I took a bishop threats
of Knight g2 and Knight see two checker
in the air
kingi two Knight takes so I sacrificed
my queen for two bishops and two pawns
in this position it's considered and I
believe rightfully so that white has an
advantage because what has stayed on the
board is a position where blacks pieces
are not active like they were in those
previous examples gary played rook here
I play Knight here Garry played the
standard Knight age three I play
we'll be legally will what did I play
help lf6 yay night here
I played Bishop d7 he played oops
no he didn't do that no no no I played
f6 he played night here very good move
new variation new mainline night here
these up to this moment this stuff was
all standard and I played a novelty
night seat 8 which was very very very
good and the game eventually ended in a
draw but I prefer the Queen here
principally for two reasons the I prefer
the Queen in this position principally
for two reasons first of all this Bishop
is passive second of all this night on a
six is not on the game but I still made
a draw we go back and this was I
remember when I first saw this this was
like a an amazing game control what for
a second hexed he's black he's white
Michael tall is black we have yeah I
think it was another was it a same ish
yeah I believe this was the same ish
Bishop III a new variation oh sorry
excuse me
cancel f3 castles Bishop e3 Michael tall
played c5 this is a very complicated
theoretical discussion after pawn takes
pawn takes Queen takes rook takes Bishop
takes e5 white wins upon but it's tons
of complex variations after knight c6
Knight d5 y 6 numerous games have been
shown and I think the final ward was a
game between
Albert as white and garry kasparov as
black and gary one with black and
capturing the pawn is frowned upon I
just say night GE to standard move
knight c6 all standard moves all of
these moves are standard moves castles
aged a6 I believe King b1 rook here so
we get the standard position and it's
white to play and Hecht played this move
Knight d5 against Michael tall and tall
came up with a concept that was just so
cool I just thought that this was really
really great tall captured here Queen
takes and of course Hecht had literally
written on his score sheet Knight takes
a five you need to anticipate it takes
and takes and he thought well we're
gonna get into an ending where you know
there's no attack against White's King
and White has more space in the center
he was looking forward to a fine
position and tall captured dead pal
captured the piece instead sacrificing
his Queen for two pieces then after the
Queen dropped back to e one tall played
either be 5:00 or night takes and tall
did not take the rook tall played either
he took this or I think he actually even
went b5 and this was a typical Michael
tall combination yeah I think he played
b5 so you know there's hacked with these
with it you know this Queen you know for
two pieces and he's looking at the Queen
and the two pieces off the board but
look at what remains on the board even
though there's no pawns at this moment
in Black's pocket so to speak it's
really really clear that this Bishop on
g7 this rook on b8 this Knight which I
do and I have it in my mind that this
night ended up going to sea for faulty
memory gray matter and all that good
stuff or no maybe it was something like
rook c1v takes e4 something like this
and we see that black is having all the
fun I mean black is the one in charge
here and of course you cannot capture
this pawn on c5 or move your pawn to d5
because rook takes B to check is an
absolute disaster so in this case it was
a case of the two pieces actually doing
a lot of damage to White's position and
tall one a very very beautiful game and
it made a very powerful impression on me
when I first saw this game just because
you know geez all you're getting all
you're getting is a knight in Bishop for
your queen but again it's not what you
getting it's what you got on the board
and what's on the board is a very nice
position for black
just to that no I'm sure you've I've
shown this game or you're least familiar
with the game perhaps some of you are
not and it's just a fun game okay so the
game I'm about to show you is called
dreams and nightmares dreams and
nightmares tonight oh what's that
so what's the dream the dream the dream
is you have the amateur player B player
a player doesn't matter plays in the big
tournament first round he gets paired up
and he's playing on board one you know
that nice little area where all the
ropes are you know it's plenty on board
one against the big grandmaster yeah
yeah exactly
and his dream is man and he's gonna play
the game of his life win a brilliantly
upset the Grandmaster and you know
that's it you know he you know he's got
drinks for the rest of his life you know
like okay nice dream flipside of that
coin is the nightmare
there's the Grandmaster right he's
playing board one against some very low
rated player guy comes in and beats the
snot out of it you know you lose 500
gazillion rating points you know every
you know your life the career is over I
mean that's the nightmare
okay that's the setup I'm playing in a
tournament that it's like three rounds
on Saturday two games on Sunday first
game starts at 10:00 o'clock on the
half-an-hour driving from the playing
home set my alarm 8:00 o'clock in the
morning about 955 my eyes wake up the
alarm didn't go off
panic panic panic panic so now instead
of you know calling the organizer and
explaining my predicament taking a
half-point by whatever you know I
scramble boy I'm resting brushing my
teeth rushing downstairs driving like a
maniac in the time control with
something like 40 moves in 90 minutes
followed by half an hour or something
like that
for the rest of the game by the time I
fly into the tournament hall I'm like
fifty minutes late fifty five zero five
zero I'm fifty minutes late and I'm
playing against Michael Darby and my
goal is you know like he's got his
opening move on the board and I bought I
apologize I explained the situation says
no problem before now in those days I
had the universal panacea I mean this
move d7 d6 it was a cure-all you could
play it against everything that white
opens up it's a it's a it's essentially
a early fianchetto with the King's
Bishop c4 g6 Knight c3 Bishop g7 C for
now literally my career I probably had
this position a thousand times in
tournament chess a thousand play e5 now
of course my opponent can get capture on
e5 I capture he trades Queens I've
played that ending for ever and I've
done very well my opponent played in
those days what it was considered the
most standard moves Bishop e3 I played
knight c6 and he played night ge2 now I
probably had this position in my career
about 400 times you know like okay and
this is a really cool move for black at
least I liked it a lot like if I played
a standard move Knight f6 and they
played an f3 and I played castles or
positions like a Samish very very normal
for me famous radiation
I played the move Knight h6 okay now I
really like this move very much this is
a very very cool move in the first place
I want to jump to g4 to harass this
bishop in the second case like most
Kings Indians I want to play the move
five with my night on h6 instead of
being in front of the pawn is actually
supporting the pawn advance F 5 F 3 F 5
and again I probably had this position
about 50 times in my chess career and at
that time everybody knew that this move
Queen d2 is a mistake that is to say in
the books it was written a question mark
and that the book suggested that white
has to play the move D 597 and only now
Queen d2 and then Knight f7 and we've
got a kind of a funky Kings Indian where
I've got in an early f5 and white still
has to solve what he's going to do in
terms of development okay but oh I must
say at this point too that my opponent
was playing at a steady pace like a
minute minute and a half per move where
I was playing nearly instantly and
scrambling to get a cup of coffee right
so he just thought about this position a
few minutes he played Queen d2 and I was
very very happy of course because now I
you know I instantly played the
refutation this is the known reputation
of Queen d2 I mean again Queen d2
question mark II takes f5 takes e4 black
is better black is better how cool is
that blacks better instantly you know
I'm off the hook you know my opponents
thinking and what's the point of course
the point is you cannot take my knight
if you take my knight I have this nasty
little check and I recover the bishop
wonderful
but here's the cool point what about
Bishop g5 oooh
Bishop g5 if the Queen move
then I'll take the night there's no
Queen check if the night blocks the
attack of the bishop I'll take the night
and there's no Queen check doesn't white
win a piece no no white doesn't win a
piece because black has this really cute
little move III okay
cutting the electricity the current
between the Queen and the bishop you
can't take my queen I'll take your queen
with check and I'll recapture your
bishop if you capture this pawn that was
the move I needed you brought your queen
into the range of the night and if you
take my queen now I'll take your queen
oh my have a nasty thread of check if
you move your Queen Queen d2 I'll move
my queen and thanks to the coordinated
efforts of this night this night this
pawn this Bishop I'm going to win
control over the d4 square and again the
books give all of this and they say
blacks better and so forth and so on
they also say that black is better and I
believe them that if you capture this
pawn I'll capture your pawn and a knight
goes to g4 and it ends up on this very
very comfortable outpost on e5 blacks
better I'll agree so that leaves the the
last choice for white is Knight takes e4
after Knight takes e4 the idea for black
is Knight f5 Bishop g5 Queen d7 this is
all given in the books by the way d5
Knight here takes takes check here takes
takes castles and the idea is that this
Bishop is under attack
if the bishop were to retreat let's just
pick a spot doesn't matter it Bishop h4
black has this great
takes three and thanks to the fact that
after GF Knight takes for King and Queen
black is doing excellent simply
excellent so there I was looking forward
to a fast victory and forget about my
early morning panic when my opponent
played d5 against me new variation and
this one so I'm thinking to myself well
what's that like that's not in your list
of options you know I got you got to go
then you read my book I mean okay
you're not supposed to play d5 well I
started to think and I quickly realized
well obviously I can't move my knight he
takes my my knight and I don't have this
Queen h4 check because my Knights in my
way so obviously I can't move my knight
to e7
I can't move my knight to d4 because
white would simply capture everything
and at the end of the day at the end of
the variation castles Knight takes e4
Knight f5 Queen drops back and what's
that I'm a pawn down I don't see any
compensation here whatsoever for black
white is ready to castle put his bishop
on d3 complete development I'm a pawn
down and my king is actually even a
little bit vulnerable so obviously in
this position my knight can't go there
but I know my opponents made a mistake
it's in the book it's in the book Queen
d2 question mark so realizing my knight
can't move I played the obvious or a by
process of elimination I mean to say
takes so I took the pawn
so at this point you know Matthew goes
into a deep think right a deep think so
this gives me the time I need to finish
my second cup of coffee get two donuts
the sugar kicks it man and suddenly I
realize I'm dead lost like dead dead
dead lost dead lost
Wow and no matter how I try to flip the
pieces in my mind I can't escape the
fact I'm lost and I mean this is like a
cold discovery I mean you know I I'm
chilled to the bone I realize and this
is very obviously the positions very
complex pieces are hanging every word
this guy is hanging that guys hanging
that guys having hanging how do you
calculate the victory for white or even
put another way how do you calculate
period okay so what's your first your
first in the order of calculation your
first thing is always checks you always
look at checks first well it's white to
move and he can't give me check so
there's no checks the second thing is if
there's no checks you always look at
captures first obviously white could
capture this pawn but that's not the
capture you're interested you got to
capture the pieces that have the
greatest value so the very first move
white should calculate this to take the
night and that's the winning move is to
take this night obviously I'm a piece
down I got it
get my piece back I'm going to take his
night
now here you have to think for a moment
and this is this is actually kind of a
difficult thing for black for white to
see it's easy for white to reject this
variation because he sees that this pawn
is about to take this bishop with a jack
and if the bishop takes the pawn bishop
takes e2 well that gives me them the
moment I need to be able to move my
knight out of hurry out of danger I can
play Knight f7 amongst other things
white could take this pond Bishop takes
Bishop takes same thing I'll move my
knight and I'll be fine
what white needed to conceive is look at
blacks Queen for a moment blacks Queen
has a very limited number of squares
thanks to the peculiar situation of the
pawn on c6 if white makes the move
Bishop g5 uh-oh
my Queens trapped if I take the bishop
rook would recapture my Queens trapped I
have no choice I must play the move
Bishop f6 to avoid my queen being trap
white captures the bishop again I have
no time to capture the bishop on f1
Wacek because then my queen would be
trapped
i must instead capture the bishop and
then my knight is captured well i'm a
piece down I really have no option I
must capture capture now where does my
Queen go oh oh if my Queen were to
retreat to d8 well after Queen g7 I'm
facing the threat
of Queen f7 checkmate as well as Queen
takes h8 I can resign if I move my Queen
to e7 well this is refuted by the
natural 95 I mean just ah
nightmares indeed right nightmare is
indeed so in this position of course I
have to block the rooks attack with the
move Bishop f5 now again I saw this
whole variation and I'm playing with it
in my mind and no matter how I played
with it I just couldn't avoid this he
would take on b7 I play rook b8 and here
White has the obvious g4 I'm losing a
piece but it's worse than that
rook takes you could take on f5 in your
winning that's not disputing that but
then I might play rook takes b2 but
White has a real Powe move rook takes f5
oh no oh no not only does he win a piece
he wins a piece with tempo and he's
attacking and he's got everything and
I'm totally shellacked let's go back for
a moment and see how that happened again
because it it's really loose d fine d d
5f e takes f3 so here's the key moment
he should take my knight I'll take his
knight he should play Bishop here and
this is how he wins oops pardon me
this is how he wins the game Bishop f5
takes takes g4 and so forth so again I
was desperately trying to avoid this
oops
to avoid this line and much to my great
surprise my opponent didn't take my
knight that instead played Knight g3 now
I was so relieved that he didn't take my
knight which wins the game that I almost
wanted to shout out Yahoo I looked at
the position I jeez this is winning - I
didn't even consider this move now both
my Knights are hanging I no longer have
this Queen h4 check to recover my knight
so it's like though
you know like I'm losing here as well I
played the move Knight d4 fully
expecting that after Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen takes check King here take
the rook take the pawn queen here bishop
here I'd be lost that is to say I can't
save my knight on a1 white would have
two pieces for the rook but even worse
from my point of view he has domination
of this efore square one of his knights
one day is gonna park itself on e4 and
I'm dead I mean okay I I will fight of
course but it's a one-sided battle white
is simply winning so I expected that
variation and instead Michael found a
finesse he played the move Bishop g5 so
he wants the variation I just showed you
but he wants me to put my queen on this
embarrassing square d7 so that after
Queen d7 I'm blocking my bishop and it's
even worse
for me then the variation I showed you I
of course played Queen takes Queen takes
Knight here so in this case I've
sacrificed my queen for a single bishop
not to pieces not three pieces a single
Bishop and I was elated I was super
super happy with myself why well first
of all it seemed like everybody in the
tournament Hall through the powers of
osmosis realize that I'm lost a queen
off the board they all came up to Mike a
little like you know likes the you know
well done you know go get him you're
gonna win your game you know I'll do my
best
so first he's dealing with that second
of all I knew I was dead lost two moves
before like if he had taken my knight
now I got a chance right the second
thing the third thing that was going on
in my mind is is the position itself one
of the things that happens is like when
we win material a queen or you know for
something or a rook or something our
first instinct is to consolidate you
know just to save the fact that you know
like you know this is mine I want to
keep it and so what what is going on in
Michaels mind is that he's facing this
very unpleasant Bishop h6 so for example
if he drops back with his queen and
you're just gonna love this variation I
attack his queen with Bishop h6 he drops
back
checkmate
clean up there so how about if the Queen
were to go here well then I have check
check
check
check
check check check
kind of a wipeout you know like what
that goes going on
let's say moves this King Bishop no
check check
wait I started with a one Bishop for
Queen and I got two bishops two knights
any still in Jackie's gonna lose his
Queen anyway so so those variations of
checkmate and this windmill tactic are
scaring Darby to death while he is
receiving congratulations about the
players of the tournament home because
they're all looking at what's off the
board and that's what's on the board
my opponent played Knight g4 and I gave
him a check and he didn't want to go to
this file to this diagonal I beg your
pardon because then I'm going to take
his rook and so he moved his King here I
play check he didn't want to go to the
diagonal as before because that's a very
unusual discovered check on the Queen
and white would have to give up his
Queen for the bishop Queen takes but in
this case I'm a pawn up yay
so he played his King pardon me after
this check he played his king here
I went Bishop here attacking his Queen
he went Queen here I took the rook came
there
I took the rook came here and here we
shook hands as we were shaking hands the
people in the tournament hall came over
to shake his hand thinking he hit one
they were shocked when I said no no I
won the game because again that was just
so focused on what came off the board
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]